In your average children's movie, people dream outlandish dreams. I wish I could be part of that world. Teenie, I wish for you to make me a prince. And then, after 90 minutes of struggle and sound effects, they achieved those dreams. Wooo! Thank you! We did it! In the end, Charlie Bucket won a chocolate factory. We think of these stories as fantasies, fairy tales, but what if science could help make our deepest hopes and desires seem less out of reach?
在普通的儿童电影中，人们总是做着天马行空的梦。我希望我能成为那个世界的一部分。蒂妮，我希望你能让我成为王子。然后，经过90分钟的挣扎和音效渲染，他们实现了这些梦想。呜！谢谢！我们做到了！最后，查理·巴克特赢得了一家巧克力工厂。我们认为这些故事是幻想、童话，但如果科学能帮助我们实现最深切的希望和愿望，让它们看起来不再那么遥不可及呢？
Today, as part of our U2.0 series, we bring you an episode from our archive that asks, is there a methodical way to achieve your dreams? Turns out, there is, and this scientific technique has an acronym. Woop! This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There's so much in our popular culture about the power of positive thinking. We're often told to follow our hearts, to dream big. You can have, do, or be anything you want. Whatever belief you hold in your subconscious mind will become your reality. Bottom line.
今天，作为我们U2.0系列的一部分，我们为您带来一期来自档案的节目，探讨是否有一种系统的方法来实现你的梦想？事实证明，确实有，而且这种科学技术有一个缩写词。WOOP！这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在我们的流行文化中，关于积极思维的力量有很多说法。我们经常被告知要追随内心，要敢于梦想。你可以拥有、去做或成为任何你想成为的人。你在潜意识中持有的任何信念都会成为你的现实。归根结底就是这样。
Value yourself and believe in yourself. Because believing that the dots will connect down the road, will give you the confidence to follow your heart, even when it leads you off the well-worn path. But now, research a Gabrielle Eddie and says, maybe we should all dream a little smaller. Positive fantasies and daydreams as pleasurable they are, they have a problem when it comes to fulfilling our wishes
珍视自己，相信自己。因为相信未来的点滴终会串联起来，会给你追随内心的信心，即使它引导你偏离了常规的道路。但现在，加布里埃尔·厄廷根的研究表明，也许我们都应该把梦想做得小一点。积极的幻想和白日梦虽然令人愉悦，但在实现我们的愿望方面却存在问题。
and attaining our goals. Gabrielle is a professor at New York University, an author of the book, Rethinking Positive Thinking, inside the new science of motivation. She's from Germany, and she said growing up, no one told her to shoot for the stars. I was raised in Europe, and the idea of big dreams, big hopes was if adult more implicit than explicit. When she came to the United States, though, Gabrielle noticed a real cultural difference.
以及实现我们的目标。加布里埃尔是纽约大学的教授，也是《重新思考积极思维：动机的新科学》一书的作者。她来自德国，她说在成长过程中，没有人告诉她要志存高远。我在欧洲长大，关于大梦想、大希望的想法，与其说是明确的，不如说是隐含的。然而，当她来到美国时，加布里埃尔注意到了一种真正的文化差异。
Well when I came to the America it was wonderful because people always said yes do it yes that's possible yeah okay this is a good idea why don't you do it? Whereas back in Europe people were more cautious and said you know are you sure you want to do this? Are you sure this is possible? So I was really happy to come to America because people were just sort of encouraging whatever idea you had. So yes, positive thinking, indulging in fantasies about the future. It does feel good. But when Gabrielle Hattie and Big Yandt research this topic, she found something interesting. Well, these positive fantasies, they seduce us to feel already accomplished and they take our energy away. So we found that, for example, they're more positively women enrolled in
嗯，当我来到美国时，这太棒了，因为人们总是说，去做吧，是的，那是可能的，是的，好吧，这是一个好主意，你为什么不做呢？而在欧洲，人们更谨慎，会说，你知道，你确定你想这样做吗？你确定这可能吗？所以我很高兴来到美国，因为人们只是在鼓励你拥有的任何想法。所以是的，积极思考，沉溺于对未来的幻想。这确实感觉很好。但当加布里埃尔·厄廷根研究这个话题时，她发现了一些有趣的事情。嗯，这些积极的幻想诱使我们感到已经成功了，它们消耗了我们的能量。所以我们发现，例如，她们在减肥计划中表现得更积极。
a weight reduction program. The few pounds they lost, three months later, one year later, two years later. Or the more positively university graduates fantasized about an easy transition into work life, the fewer dollars they earned two years later, the fewer drop offers they had gotten, and also the fewer drop applications they had sent out. Or take students, the more positively they fantasized about getting a good grade in their exam, the less well they did. Or the more positively they fantasized about getting together with a crushy, the less likely they were to actually get in a romantic relationship.
她们减掉的几磅体重，三个月后，一年后，两年后。或者大学毕业生对顺利过渡到工作生活幻想得越积极，他们两年后赚的钱就越少，得到的录用通知就越少，发出的求职申请也越少。或者以学生为例，他们对在考试中取得好成绩幻想得越积极，他们的表现就越差。或者他们对与暗恋对象在一起幻想得越积极，他们真正建立恋爱关系的可能性就越小。
Or take the health domain. Same thing, the more positively hip replacement surgery patients fantasized about an easy recovery, the less well could they move their joint, the fewer steps they could take and the less well they recovered from the surgery. So when you look at each of these cases, I'm wondering if you could tell me what you mean by a positive fantasy So let's take the student for example who is hoping to go out on a date with Someone that he or she likes. You're sort of imagining for example going out on the date things going really well
或者以健康领域为例。同样的事情，髋关节置换手术的患者对康复得越积极，他们的关节活动能力就越差，他们能走的步数就越少，手术后的恢复情况也越差。所以当你审视这些案例时，我想知道你能不能告诉我你所说的积极幻想是什么意思？让我们以那个希望与喜欢的人约会的学生为例。你是在想象，比如去约会，事情进展得非常顺利。
There's other person really liking you as much as you like them. Yeah, that's a good question actually It's not so easy to measure these fantasies So what we did is we gave participants a short story. So for example, in the case of the people who had a crush on someone else, a short story describing how they meet this person and they then needed to end that story. And that story could either end positively or it could end not so positively.
对方也像你喜欢他们一样喜欢你。是的，这确实是一个好问题。测量这些幻想并不容易，所以我们给参与者讲了一个短篇故事。例如，在那些暗恋别人的人的案例中，一个短篇故事描述了他们如何遇见这个人，然后他们需要结束那个故事。那个故事可以以积极的方式结束，也可以以不那么积极的方式结束。
So then participants fantasized and wrote down their fantasies about the ending of the story. And the more positively these people had been fantasizing about getting together with their crushy, then less likely it was that they actually got together with the person they were in love. So the idea really is, the more idealized, the more positively people fantasize, the less well they do, because they don't put in the effort needed to actually reach the goals and fulfill the wishes. Now, is it the case that people recovering from example hip replacement surgery when they have positive fantasies of walking? At one level, you would have to say
所以参与者幻想并写下了他们对故事结局的幻想。而这些人对与暗恋对象在一起幻想得越积极，他们真正与所爱之人在一起的可能性就越小。所以真正的想法是，人们幻想得越理想化、越积极，他们的表现就越差，因为他们没有投入实现目标和满足愿望所需的努力。那么，例如髋关节置换手术的患者在对行走进行积极幻想时，情况是这样吗？在某种程度上，你不得不说
this is deeply, deeply understandable. You know, you feel like you can't do the things that you're used to doing. You want to get back on your feet and you want to dream of the day when you would be able to walk or climb stairs or run without pain. Are you saying that that's a bad thing? No, I'm not saying it's a bad thing.
这是非常、非常可以理解的。你知道，你觉得你无法做你习惯做的事情。你想重新站起来，你想梦想有一天你能走路、爬楼梯或跑步而不会感到疼痛。你是说那是一件坏事吗？不，我不是说那是一件坏事。
Actually, we have very nice data showing that these positive fantasies, they actually come out of a person's needs and you are completely right. A person who has a surgery and who used to be able to walk feels a need to walk like before and they are the positive fantasies come from. And I don't say these are bad things at all because they are the beginning of action, but they are only the beginning. They give action the direction, but they don't give action the necessary energy. In fact, when we induce participants to positively fantasize, to
事实上，我们有非常好的数据表明，这些积极的幻想实际上源于一个人的需求，你是完全正确的。一个做过手术且曾经能够行走的人感到需要像以前一样行走，这就是积极幻想的来源。我一点也不说这些是坏事，因为它们是行动的开始，但它们只是开始。它们为行动提供了方向，但它们没有为行动提供必要的能量。事实上，当我们诱导参与者进行积极幻想时，去
ideally depict them, positive future, then we find that the blood pressure goes down, and then we find that the feelings of energization go down. And we find that people feel already accomplished. So they relax. They relax because mentally, they're already there. There's something terribly sad about this, which is that the person imagines the happy future, perhaps because they're not very happy at the present. But by so doing, they in some ways
理想化地描绘他们，积极的未来，然后我们发现血压下降，然后我们发现被激励的感觉下降。我们发现人们感到已经成功了。所以他们放松了。他们放松是因为在心理上，他们已经到达了那里。这其中有一些非常悲伤的事情，那就是这个人想象着幸福的未来，也许是因为他们现在过得并不快乐。但通过这样做，他们在某种程度上
deprive themselves of the energy and motivation they need to make their futures actually better, and thereby make their futures worse. It feels like a vicious cycle. Well, it is not so sad if you consider that if you actually complement these positive fantasies with considerations of what stands in the way, what is it in you that stands in the way that you actually fulfill your wishes and attain your goals, that then you actually get the energy and if these goals are attainable, then you really go for it. When we come back, we'll talk about the next steps to make that day dream a reality.
剥夺了他们使未来真正变得更好所需的能量和动力，从而使他们的未来变得更糟。这感觉像是一个恶性循环。嗯，如果你考虑到如果你实际上用对阻碍因素的考虑来补充这些积极的幻想，是什么阻碍了你真正实现愿望和达到目标，那么你实际上就会获得能量，如果这些目标是可以实现的，那么你就会真正去追求它。当我们回来时，我们将讨论将白日梦变为现实的后续步骤。
You think about the next four weeks. Now in the next four weeks, what is your most important wish? Stay with us. Gabrielle Adian has found that positive thinking, while fun, may not really be the answer to achieving your goals, but she does say that noticing your dreams and thinking about what you really want can be the first step to making them a reality. You've done a lot of work looking not just at the potential downside of these positive fantasies, but also how we can use these positive fantasies in a very productive way and you call it mental contrasting. What is mental contrasting?
你考虑接下来的四周。现在在接下来的四周里，你最重要的愿望是什么？请继续收听。加布里埃尔·厄廷根发现，积极思考虽然有趣，但可能并不是实现目标的答案，但她确实说，注意到你的梦想并思考你真正想要的东西可能是实现它们的第一步。你做了很多工作，不仅研究了这些积极幻想的潜在负面影响，还研究了我们如何以一种非常有效的方式利用这些积极幻想，你称之为心理对照。什么是心理对照？
Mental contrasting is a strategy to fulfill your wishes and attain your goals. So, you first identify a wish. A wish that is very dear to you. So for example, you think about the next four weeks. Now in the next four weeks, what is your most important wish? Can be a professional wish, can be an interpersonal wish, can be health wish. This wish should be a wish that is a little challenging for you, but that you actually can fulfill yourself. Now identify that wish and keep it in front of your mind. What you do then is you think about what would be the best thing, the best outcome, if I fulfilled myself that wish.
心理对照是一种实现你的愿望和达到你的目标的策略。所以，你首先确定一个愿望。一个对你非常珍贵的愿望。例如，你考虑接下来的四周。现在在接下来的四周里，你最重要的愿望是什么？可以是职业愿望，可以是人际关系愿望，可以是健康愿望。这个愿望应该是一个对你来说有点挑战性，但你实际上可以自己实现的愿望。现在确定那个愿望并把它放在你的脑海里。然后你做的是思考，如果我实现了那个愿望，最好的事情、最好的结果会是什么。
And once you identify that and put it in front of your mind, then you imagine that best thing. If you recognize now, imagining that best thing is like positively fantasizing, these are the positive data, so he's just talking about. But then instead of carrying on with these positive fantasies, you know which gears, and you say to yourself, actually, what stops me from fulfilling my wish and experiencing that outcome? and experiencing that outcome. What is it in me that stands in the way? What is my inner obstacle? What is it in me?
一旦你确定了这一点并把它放在你的脑海里，然后你想象那件最好的事情。如果你现在意识到，想象那件最好的事情就像积极幻想，这就是他刚才谈到的积极数据。但随后，你没有继续这些积极的幻想，你知道换挡，你对自己说，实际上，是什么阻止了我实现我的愿望并体验那个结果？并体验那个结果。是什么阻碍了我？我的内在障碍是什么？是什么阻碍了我？
And then once you identified your inner obstacle and you need a little bit of humor and a little bit of honesty to yourself. Sometimes it's not so pleasant. You don't need to tell anybody, but you can identify that obstacle, and then you say to yourself, if that obstacle occurs, then I will show a behavior or think of a thought
然后一旦你确定了你的内在障碍，你需要一点幽默感和一点对自己诚实。有时这并不那么令人愉快。你不需要告诉任何人，但你可以确定那个障碍，然后你对自己说，如果那个障碍发生，那么我将表现出一种行为或产生一个想法
to overcome that obstacle. So if obstacle obstacle then I will behavior to overcome obstacle. And that's what in the science language is called mental contrasting with implementation intentions and to forget this complicated name it's called in the science literature also MCII, but we renamed it now and it's called now whoop for wish. First we started with a wish. Outcome, we then went on to identify that outcome and imagine that outcome. Obstacle, remember the obstacle, identify the obstacle, imagine the obstacle, and then the plan. The if obstacle, identify the obstacle, imagine the obstacle, and then the plan. The if
来克服那个障碍。所以如果障碍发生，那么我将采取行为来克服障碍。这就是科学语言中所说的带有执行意图的心理对照，为了忘记这个复杂的名字，它在科学文献中也被称为MCII，但我们现在重新命名了它，现在它被称为WOOP，代表愿望。首先我们从愿望开始。结果，我们接着确定那个结果并想象那个结果。障碍，记住障碍，确定障碍，想象障碍，然后是计划。如果障碍，确定障碍，想象障碍，然后是计划。如果
obstacle, then I will overcome plan. And that's called whoop. I asked Gabrielle how she would apply her strategy to someone who has a crush on another person, but instead of doing something about it, it's just sitting around daydreaming about a blissful honeymoon. What would that person do if they wanted to use mental contrasting? Or who? So let's say you have a young person who's interested in another person. And so the wish would be, you know, I want to go with him or with her on a date, and want to explore a little bit deeper what that person is all about. So there will be the wish. The best outcome might be something like, you know, we would have a really good time and we would feel kind of in harmony.
障碍，那么我将克服计划。这就是所谓的WOOP。我问加布里埃尔，她将如何把她的策略应用到那些暗恋别人，但不是采取行动，而是坐着做关于幸福蜜月的白日梦的人身上。如果那个人想使用心理对照，那个人会做什么？或者WOOP？所以假设你有一个对另一个人感兴趣的年轻人。所以愿望会是，你知道，我想和他或她去约会，我想更深入地探索那个人到底是什么样的人。所以那将是愿望。最好的结果可能是，你知道，我们会玩得很开心，我们会感到某种和谐。
But then the person would change gears and say, what is it in me that stands in the way that I actually fulfill my wish, that I ask this person out for a date and experience the harmony. So what is it in me that stands in the way? And then the person might discover, hmm, I might feel too shy, or I'm a little bit anxious, reluctant to get a rejection, and then the person can elaborate on their China's to be rejected, or that fear of rejection can really elaborate on it, understand, oh yeah, this fear, that's my obstacle.
但随后那个人会换挡并说，是什么阻碍了我真正实现我的愿望，让我约这个人出去约会并体验和谐。所以是什么阻碍了我？然后那个人可能会发现，嗯，我可能觉得太害羞了，或者我有点焦虑，不愿意被拒绝，然后那个人可以详细说明他们被拒绝的羞怯，或者那种对拒绝的恐惧可以真正详细说明它，理解，哦是的，这种恐惧，这就是我的障碍。
And after that, the person could think, what can I do to overcome this fear of rejection? So what can the person do? The person can sort of understand, well, if the person rejected me, then I'm there where I'm right now. Because if I don't talk to that person, I will not meet the person anyway. So I can't really lose anything. And then he actually could do the if-then plan.
在那之后，那个人可以思考，我能做些什么来克服这种对拒绝的恐惧？所以那个人能做什么？那个人可以理解，嗯，如果那个人拒绝了我，那么我就处在我现在的位置。因为如果我不和那个人说话，我无论如何也不会见到那个人。所以我真的没有什么可失去的。然后他实际上可以制定如果-那么计划。
If I feel that fear of rejection, then I will tell myself, just go to that person and approach him or her, because I can't lose anything. And then the person will non-consciously, outside of awareness, approach that person by sort of overcoming one's fears of rejection. One of the things that I find so striking is that third step doesn't involve saying what are the obstacles in my path but you ask what are
如果我感到那种对拒绝的恐惧，那么我会告诉自己，直接去找那个人并接近他或她，因为我没有什么可失去的。然后那个人会无意识地，在意识之外，通过克服对拒绝的恐惧来接近那个人。我发现最引人注目的一件事是，第三步不涉及说我道路上的障碍是什么，而是你问
the obstacles in me that prevent me from achieving the score. That's correct because the obstacles in me doesn't allow me to come up with all these excuses. So if I say, what are the obstacles in my path, I could say, well, this person is in a different building or whatever, or studies a different topic, or I don't have the time, or I'm just busy right now, all these excuses they fall away if you ask, what is it in you that stands in the way? What is it really that stands in the way? Now you extract the information out of that negative feedback without getting hurt.
阻碍我实现这个目标的我内在的障碍是什么。这是正确的，因为我内在的障碍不允许我提出所有这些借口。所以如果我说，我道路上的障碍是什么，我可以说，嗯，这个人是在不同的建筑物里，或者无论什么，或者学习不同的主题，或者我没有时间，或者我现在只是很忙，所有这些借口如果你问，是什么阻碍了你？真正阻碍你的是什么？现在你从那些负面反馈中提取信息而不会受到伤害。
So you don't take it personally, but you take the information and compost in this negative feedback and you use it to make the correct plans. Has metal contrasting changed anything that you do? Well, I'm using a wop on a daily basis and we have devised next to the book we have devised an app which gives you the instructions of mental contrasting with implementation and intentions of WOOP. So it leads you through the four steps which outcome, obstacle, plan. And interestingly enough, I thought I'm an expert on WOO poop, but I'm using the app every day actually. I'm using the app because it forces me to specify my wish, to specify my outcome, to imagine the outcome,
所以你不会把它个人化，但你接受信息并把这些负面反馈堆肥，你用它来制定正确的计划。心理对照改变了你的任何做法吗？嗯，我每天都在使用WOOP，除了这本书，我们还设计了一个应用程序，它为你提供了带有执行意图的心理对照的说明，即WOOP。所以它引导你完成四个步骤，即结果、障碍、计划。有趣的是，我以为我是WOOP的专家，但我实际上每天都在使用这个应用程序。我使用这个应用程序是因为它强迫我明确我的愿望，明确我的结果，想象结果，
to specify my inner obstacle, to imagine the inner obstacle, and to form a very specific if obstacle, then I will behave to overcome obstacle plan. So I do it every morning, other people do it in the evening, or you know, doing lunch break, or when they wait for the bus, or in the subway. What you need though for doing a group, you need to have a quiet moment for yourself. You can be in some way when everybody is talking, but you need to be uninterrupted. You can't do your email, you can't talk to someone while you're doing a group. So you need to have a moment for yourself where you think,
明确我的内在障碍，想象内在障碍，并形成一个非常具体的如果障碍，那么我将采取行为来克服障碍的计划。所以我每天早上都这样做，其他人晚上做，或者你知道，午休时做，或者当他们等公共汽车或在地铁里时。不过，做WOOP你需要的是，你需要有一个安静的时刻给自己。你可以在某种程度上在每个人都在说话的时候做，但你需要不被打扰。你不能在做WOOP时处理电子邮件，你不能和别人说话。所以你需要有一个属于你自己的时刻，在那里你思考，
what is my wish for today, or you might think, what is my wish for the next four weeks? Or what do I want in life? What is it really that I want? So you can whoop, very big wishes, or you can whoop, trivial wishes. But what is important, it needs to be a wish which is dear to your heart. And the nice thing with whoop is that it also allows you to finally think about what do I really want. Gabrielle Etienne is a professor of psychology at New York University.
我今天的愿望是什么，或者你可能会想，我接下来的四周的愿望是什么？或者我生活中想要什么？我真正想要的是什么？所以你可以WOOP非常大的愿望，或者你可以WOOP琐碎的愿望。但重要的是，它必须是一个你内心珍视的愿望。WOOP的好处在于它也让你最终思考我真正想要什么。加布里埃尔·厄廷根是纽约大学的心理学教授。
This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Penman and Max Nestrak. Our team includes Jennifer Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Lucy Perkins, Parth Shah, and Renee Clarre. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. This week's unsung hero is Jessica Goldstein, who's the director of events and strategic initiatives at NPR. Jessica helped with our live taping in Aspen a few weeks ago.
本期《隐藏的大脑》由玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作。我们的团队包括詹妮弗·施密特、雷娜·科恩、露西·珀金斯、帕斯·沙阿和蕾妮·克莱尔。我们的监制是塔拉·博伊尔。本周的无名英雄是杰西卡·戈尔茨坦，她是NPR活动和战略倡议的主管。几周前，杰西卡帮助了我们在阿斯彭的现场录制。
She's someone who dots the eyes and crosses the tees, and then goes back and double checks everything. Thanks Jessica. One last thing before we go, we're working on a story about male friendships. This new research that suggests that many men, especially over the age of 50, find themselves with fewer friends and intimate relationships than they had in their 20s and 30s. Loneliness and social isolation are powerful determinants of health and well-being. If you're a man over the age of 50 who's willing to share with us a story about the effect that loneliness has on your life, please give us a call at 661-772-7246.
她是一个注重细节、一丝不苟，然后回去仔细检查一切的人。谢谢你，杰西卡。在我们离开之前还有最后一件事，我们正在制作一个关于男性友谊的故事。这项新研究表明，许多男性，尤其是50岁以上的男性，发现自己拥有的朋友和亲密关系比他们在20多岁和30多岁时要少。孤独和社会孤立是健康和幸福的强大决定因素。如果你是一位50岁以上愿意与我们分享孤独对你生活影响的故事的男性，请致电661-772-7246。
That's 661-77-bra Brain. You can also record a voice memo on your smartphone and email it to us at hiddenbrainatnpr.org. Again, that's hiddenbrain1wordatnpr.org. And thanks. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. And this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是661-77-BRAIN。你也可以在智能手机上录制语音备忘录并将其通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是hiddenbrain@npr.org。再说一遍，那是hiddenbrain@npr.org。谢谢。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这是NPR。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。